What's up everybody! We are Pongfinity and welcome to another episode of Challenge Pongfinity.
This is the series were you challenge us.
With your craziest ideas related to table tennis.
If your comment gets picked, we will feature it in our next video and give you a shout out.
So make sure you leave your comments in the comment section below!
Shreyas Ravi wants us to throw a ball in the air and hit it with another ball
Okay, that was too easy. Now, let's try with two balls.
Jai Motwani wants us to play with a camera.
I'll use this GoPro and let's see how it goes.
Lim Aik Yuan wants to play table tennis with a pillow.
Let's see what we can do with it.
Straight on the camera!
Previously I did 20 around the net shots.
Now Omco Ball Ball wants me to do 30. Let's go!
Easy.
Thanks for watching guys! if you enjoyed this episode make sure to leave it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel right here!
And if you want to buy this kind of merch click here and watch the previous episodes here.
Until next time!